you are pregnant yeah well that's a
risky move that's embarrassing my girl
has a couple extra sandwiches and then
this is gonna be maybe two maybe number
two how far along are you
I'm about seven months yeah are you the
kind of couple that finds out what
you're having or do you is it a surprise
it's a surprise it's a surprise we don't
know this time we didn't know last time
last time I had to find out that I was
having a son or that I had had a son
because I'd given birth and I was
holding my beautiful baby in my arms
looking at the beautiful perfect face
just thinking it's perfect and I heard
my partner Norman say holy cow look at
the size of the balls on that kid so
your son's name is unique right it's hi
Keely Kahekili yes which obviously
Hawaiian name no Irish actually I would
know anything about odd names but Chaya
Keely means something what does it mean
it means the thunder the thunder that is
such a cool I looked up Conan once and
in Gaelic it's like broad forehead okay
let's say you the second child is there
do you plan out names ahead of time do
you know if it's a boy or a girl or do
you wait for some kind of just
inspiration to hit you we go we got so
lucky we are the laziest parents ever we
didn't have a single name for our first
child not one idea if it was a boy or a
girl and then he just happened to be
born in this epic crazy thunderstorm
like Oh obviously he's got a Kili right
and this one we're hoping to see this
same might happen because we still don't
have any names for this child
I think Ely mudslide get in here
monalee sewage backup sewage backups
like you could you I remember you
telling me you did a home birth last
time that sounded it was an epic it went
on for quite a long time right are you
planning to do that again you call it
epic because you didn't have to go
through it
excuse me I went through two birds they
didn't happen quickly I mean I my wife
you went through two birds yes how did
that feel I was in a Denny's nearby
occasionally I'd turn down the TV to
find out what was going on a boy you say
ha ha sounds boy completely medication I
did at home and then our being outside
in a thunderstorm and you were outside
you're outside in a thunderstorm wearing
a tinfoil helmet there island-wide power
outage at the moment of his birth so it
was dark and there was no lights and it
was a bit crazy and it was it was at the
end of 30 hours of labor the hours and
eight hours of pushing hmm
which is the part that I don't know if
men will fully grasp but mother is out
there eight hours of bush yeah yeah
oh my god how do you handle the pain in
that situation I it was I was in a
fairly meditative state throughout the
entire labor probably actually too much
of a meditative state sometimes I wonder
if maybe I had come back to real life
and participated if it wouldn't have
been a bit shorter you mean you were
just what are you saying like ohm ohm
and you're I'm just trying to picture
you you're meditating and you didn't
feel the pain well you feel it but
there's this amazing thing about pain
that it's sort of like a tornado if you
can get to the center of the pain like
the deepest craziest most intense part
of the pain it's like the eye of the
storm there's sort of a it's like a
peace bear there's you're at peace but
you see cows and houses hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please